hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to hand simulator so I
might be playing some hand simulator
because I hate myself shift changes out
which hand you lower with the mouse you
grab you can just grab with everything
you can there we go
I think the problem is the tendency for
this [ __ ] to come back for some
reason I have to I have to like Express
like constant force in a certain
direction for it to be able to move and
whatever it doesn't matter
alright I did nothing - oh there we go
okay hang on alright okay at least I
don't have to unload the individual
bullets for this bad boy let me get this
bad boy right here how do I rotate their
wheel rotate hand-wrote hot eh and three
two one contact got it
hey I've even got no that's not gonna
work okay apparently I didn't have
contact all right here we go alright and
grip no no let's nut nudge nudge nudge
nudge now why are you not nudging why
why don't there we go nudge okay and
then grab and then lift slam that bad
boy home why are you lifting like that
that doesn't make any sense for a it's
not that heavy it's not gonna drag your
goddamn hand out alright ham and also
why do I have a proclivity to play these
rage games you know I don't [ __ ] know
like I said I hate myself I think that's
the only answer you get shove in you
okay hang on we're gonna switch us
Watchi
we're gonna hold you in place we're
gonna hold you switch Eastwatch ii shove
shove and hold no this is erotic
gret okay you're gonna let go you're
gonna really really slam that bad boy
okay just Pat it like an old friend grab
tight shift switch no why did you think
I just grab and shove hey what are you
doing what kind of what point are you
trying to make all right you shove right
there stay right there
you grab you
shove shove slam it home okay what if I
pick up the gun in this hand why is the
pinkie slam down like that let go of
your goddamn pinky okay what if I pick
up the gun if I pick up the gun then I I
wouldn't have a chew all right then Oh
wrote hot a wrote hot okay shift all
right we're gonna slam this bad boy home
just like I know how to spank an ass I'm
gonna slam you back what if there's one
thing mark Blair knows how to do it's
how to slap an ass I'm gonna I'm gonna
shoot the banging banging it's tough to
[ __ ] the gun after I get done with all
this bull [ __ ] I'm just trying to
position it where my hand could actually
grab it again this is one of those
skills that I just didn't want no that's
not that's not right this is a
fundamental problem of picking things up
when they're flat on the ground when
your hand behaves like a like an
epileptic badger go up apparently I
didn't need to [ __ ] it and why is my
hand drifting my hand is here I'm not
controlling this it's just drifting why
okay fine then I guess I guess we've got
this our wrote at a wrote at a road
taught a bring the aim up okay no wired
why am i leaning forward why would I be
leaning forward that makes no sense am I
trying to aim down the sights come on
bring it up no wrote out a wrote aa a
and then bring your wrist
oh that's fun that's fun you can draw a
figure eight oh okay we're gonna go
we're gonna go it's a kill shot hang on
let's do a trick shot here nope nope
okay I guess we're not gonna shoot a
shooty bang bang anymore we were in
shooty shooty bang bang position and now
we're suddenly not okay alright that's
stupid you're stupid I'm dropping you
hope good thing that that seems perfect
now watch me [ __ ] this up because it's
not perfect obviously and and it's gonna
go very wrong for me okay yeah I think
we're on target the shadows are aligned
the stars and the planets now that is a
good grip now that's how you properly
hold a gun right there
I can shoot yes okay em em em ha so
close to a headshot Oh headshot headshot
baby hey Chuck why did I get zero points
for that oh my god I don't care I got a
headshot do you guys oh my god I was
close not quite oh come on I'm right by
the head I'm right by the head oh come
on and oh jeez I'm the worst oh oh geez
okay I've got to be out of bullets by
now oh my matter bullets god
I've got so many bullets by the headsail
let me see if I can bring this goddamn
thing forward I can't believe I'm
getting better at this game I don't like
the fact that I'm getting better at this
game I should not be getting better at
this game this game is not not what I
should be doing are you here oh gods
like a horror it is scary that's scary
are you here yet that's as close you're
gonna get poisoning shadow who where
shadowed maybe I got to put it back just
a bit but you guys are gonna see how
close I was to success
no please subscribe it grab man no don't
flip me off you [ __ ] oh I just go back a
bit
are you still in shadow now where's the
bullet holes you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ]
take some of that and won't let me spawn
the other gun because I have no score
and let me see if I can do this quickly
Brett grab it gradually grasp it okay
and wrote at a wrote wrote hey maybe I
can I think I can score points I must
have just been on the outskirt of the
head and it didn't give me any points
cuz I think it costs points to get other
guns oh come on
slam it in there ah slam that hot dog
home come on just slam oh you're right
in the hole get in the hole okay if if
you're not the guns being guns being all
shy about if if I can't bring the clip
to the gun you better believe I'm gonna
bring the gun to the clip all right here
we go slam home a Slammy Slammy the
Celebi
come on salami please it's right there
wrote on a rope ha come on it's oh my
god they both don't want to be near each
other and I can't blame them
they just don't want to kill I
understand but this poor target needs to
be shot no God Frick a dick now it's the
wrong way now it's the wrong [ __ ] way
now it's the wrong [ __ ] way
okay alright I can deal with this if I
can just pick it up if I can pick it up
that'd be great
no okay let's try that again grab no
grab why what grab yes okay I guess I'll
take it you know what I don't have much
else to go by but I guess I'll take it
oh my god please just go in the hole
please just oh my god there it was in
the hole
hang on why is this so hard now why is
this suddenly
things fighting me it wasn't doing this
before okay my shift no hmm right there
shift it used to be that it would hold
it in between each one why a Mike I just
don't understand why the camera decides
to move sometimes like why would the
camera move there why is the camera
moving I don't have any control over the
[ __ ] camera come on come on you're
right you're right down oh my god ah
frickin dick okay alright let's just set
that back down what if I do it like this
what if I just try to stand it up like
no like no like no okay that's not gonna
work cuz my wrist will not Bend as far
as it needs to go okay
stand it up nope up no no no no no here
yes no no yes oh oh my god oh oh what is
this I'm not moving my hand I'm not
moving
hey wait why not moving not [ __ ]
moving it's moving I'm not moving let go
of that let's escape nope we're out
we're out okay we're out we're gonna try
I don't know what horror is but I hope
whoa hi
okay you're coming closer I don't like
that wait um whoa hey whoa there ease
ease up on it hang on whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa hey whoa whoa whoa what
are you supposed to do yeah I got rid of
the TV oh wait no hang on wait lady lady
no lady no what if I got a puncher what
if like that's the thing Han let me get
my fists of fury here all right at this
point you're walking into this
oh god my mouth put you right in the
teeth
okay all right lady by the power of my
middle finger I compel you to [ __ ] off
okay yeah way there's got to be
something right oh wait what the [ __ ] no
why me if I just don't look at her if I
don't look at her she can't get me right
if I just look at my non-existent dick I
I'll be fine right here's a bit hundred
percent okay she doesn't exist
[Laughter]
she's doing it screaming at me I mean
wouldn't you scream at someone too if
there was a naked man a Ken doll likes
naked man standing in the middle of your
living room watching your TV I mean no
no no no no no no no no no lady no no
wait maybe Tonto
come here Oh Gucci Gucci Kabyle you come
here come a little closer give me a
smooch come on don't be shy
come on it seems like certain things
that she killed me way faster than the
last time and I'm not sure why crouch
mode all right well this just seems
pressing all the buttons middle mouse
button oh I can turn okay I can turn
that doesn't oh now I can move okay so I
needed to go into look mode to be able
to get away from her ah so if you go
into look mode with the middle mouse
button you can walk perfect doesn't seem
like the most amazing thing oh I
probably needed to take that candelabra
I can't exactly see anything well
alright I guess I'm stuck
crouch mode there we go okay so I've got
a mushroom back off
I've got a mushroom okay nevermind no I
don't mmm well this is precarious I
can't see [ __ ] you're standing over here
kill me coming almost horrible I gotta
grab this candelabra or else I'm not
gonna be able to see anything right okay
shift right lower lower and slot it in
slot it in come on slot it in okay gonna
walk a little closer closer
okay slot it in down grab come on Bobby
ah [ __ ] I'll try going around the other
side and then grab me who'd have thought
that a hand simulator game mode would be
would be something challenging and
difficult oh no no please no it's my
only hope no grab it all right here let
me see one good oh okay well that almost
worked
come on come on it's okay grab there's
no grabbing happening
alright well lady look look let me let
me level with you lady I I'm struggling
to do some very basic oh I'm trying to
cast a spell as you can see by my hands
very clearly so you need to back the eff
off before I slap the [ __ ] out of you
with some magic [ __ ] okay here we go
there we go
Alek okay well I'm all right look lady
look can I can I reason with you here
you're not that scary so
here we go okay so no no quickly before
it falls before gravity makes it yes
okay I've got it
all right so I just needed to take the
light maybe I just need to leave maybe
but maybe that's all I didn't really
need all right let me light this whew
okay that's more light apparently can i
light fire to this place
can i light fire to you hmm
okay well weird like what what we're
making
where's my candelabra axe that's helpful
okay let me try the axe weird weird
might what candelabra it's in my pit get
out of my armpit candelabra okay there
we go got it okay in my other hand okay
in my other hand I shall grab an axe all
right hang on oh [ __ ] crap no no please
no grab okay I don't have it
oh please grab please I'm trying so hard
okay I got it
alright alright lady prepare to meet
your imminent demise oh that doors open
nevermind oh no you mean I can't solve
it with my huh well let me try it well
that's not right hang on it comes with a
middle finger straight for you all right
well okay I can't look up I can't look
it's so heavy
alright take some of that take some of
that I don't even have it anymore what
the [ __ ] okay that's wrong alright well
I guess that's just my arm now yeah wait
nope alright okay lady you know just
kill me I can't even get to the point
where I can try this puzzle so just
[ __ ] kill me
alright let's try that again for some
[ __ ] reason alright here we go
quickly quickly quickly speed run baby
got it alright
move like zombie we're gonna set this
here just like that don't get in my way
please light the other one all right
let's try this left Andy left Andy
because the other Andy is not not
worky-worky grab gently grasp it okay
wrote at a no wrote wrote at a oh this
is not gonna work am i over it I'm
probably over okay no no no no don't
grab your fingers oh well I'm all kinds
of [ __ ] aren't I looky loo down e1 e2
at the ground he grabbed between your
legs grab the cylinder between your legs
oh boy oh this ain't gonna work this
this just not gonna work
grab it grab kill me kill me lady kill
me where are you kill me please just
kill me I just want to die please kill
me where are you I can't see you are you
in front of me why'd the music stop oh
[ __ ] no no no crap crap crap crap
crap alright it's enough you know what I
don't need it it's fine who needs it I
certainly for one do not I can't see
[ __ ] alright I needed it apparently who
knew alright lady just just kill me
rotate a blue not a grab Bob a
kill ami Kalam II Kalam ecological ami
no no no grab grab grab why are you not
grabbing why grabbed grad just this was
my mistake a is that I wasn't crouched
okay okay here we go
grab Bob a crap crap crap how is that
not a girl crap crap crap how was that
huh how the [ __ ] is not a crap why just
grab it haven't you ever grabbed
anything cylindrical in your life I
guess this guy hasn't he doesn't have a
dick so let scratch yes no I'm free oh
no I'm not free I'm the opposite of free
hang on wait wait wait wait wait wait
wrote at a wrote at a wrote I wrote
wrote too much wrote a say too much
wrote on say oh okay back back back just
go okay well that is my back I am
scratching my back there we are and
we're almost through
let's diggle that those bones are not
supposed to wiggle like that I know that
for a fact
[Laughter]
come on come on baby
okay well Oh easy easy does it there we
go
all right okay we are making progress oh
whoa so what we got to do we got to drop
this bad boy right there get the [ __ ]
out
so let's do the easiest one first oh
that's not gonna be easy it's on the
side all right so I gotta somehow grab
it while also getting it on its side
let's try not to push it off the edge Oh
too far come on come on physics there we
go that's the good stuff okay grab that
just gently enough yeah
ah alright we're gonna just set it on
here for now no boy it's in that
position where it doesn't want to okay
we're just gonna set it right there no
oh my god
okay let's just set it raise off switch
hands cuz right II don't want to play
that game I let's just scoot sure back
scoot your back scooch scooch yeah baby
yeah baby okay
now let's raise this bad boy up on its
side just like that let's grab this bad
boy and just plunk or dunk it right in
that bad boy okay let's just let go all
right so this one is not whoa be very
careful with that okay let's switch you
swatching handy Windies come on okay
that this one doesn't want to cooperate
I thought this would have been one of
the easier ones okay put it up rotate a
row taught a row taught a back on the
correct Oh
oh man this one does not want to play
nice okay no it does not want to play
come on rotate there just like that
let's drop it on here let's just let it
go okay it's gone get that out of the
way oh god it does not want to stay holy
[ __ ] okay whatever doesn't matter she's
getting close okay she's definitely got
to be getting close so just rotate a
rota oh no rotate a let's try to let her
go oh that's new okay all right oh
[ __ ] hell
please just please the other ones went
so smoothly just let this one okay raise
extend extend extend okay just got to
drop it like this just got it let it go
no not on the edge [ __ ] me
come on just [ __ ] come on alright
just go and then drop it right on okay
[ __ ] are you serious are you [ __ ]
serious
god dammit [ __ ] this [ __ ] the [ __ ] is
going on okay now I'm oh where is she
okay still got plenty of time
alright just [ __ ] I don't know what
my arms are doing up there oh no is that
out of my range oh no it's it's oh no it
might be out of my range oh no no
no no no no no no no no no no come on
okay
Oh [ __ ] oh my god are you okay if I'm
kraut no oh my god
oh no okay it's Crouch oh my god don't
go through the [ __ ] table okay just
stay right there
just stay right oh my god oh my why why
oh I'm through the table okay well you
know what I'm not gonna complain about
it we're gonna switch where's my arm
where's my other arm where's my oh go up
no okay it's fine I got it here okay
shift shift lower no it's right there
grab it's right no oh my god where's it
it's on his head I don't care it's on
its end I don't know what the [ __ ]
happened get down and move okay let's
move let's move let's move
it's on the correct angle so let's just
grab it oh no the square the square is
underneath that one that that why no it
was right there now come on okay rotate
a gentle lot a gentle nudging no switch
handsy no no where are you going no no
no no no
[ __ ] oh my god of whatever [ __ ] oh
my god oh come on this is the most
absurd thing the other two went in so
easily I don't get why this one's
causing me trouble it should not be by
all accounts this should not be given me
any trouble oh [ __ ] okay last ditch
effort here here we go this is literally
it all or nothing here can you just
behave please I Oh Mike oh why did you
do that why why did it continually move
I wasn't [ __ ] moving the hand and
then now it's not moving it's it's just
there's nothing there's just no [ __ ]
God just there's nothing it was going in
it was going in it was going in it was
going in it was going in it was going in
going in let's go again let's do it
again
stir it again here we go let's do this
easy-peasy okay cylinder first shouldn't
be too difficult
whoa where what the [ __ ] I accidentally
hit the middle mouse button I think okay
wait okay let's just get here before it
starts destroying itself okay go in that
hole and lick Oh perfect
okay one down let's do the triangle next
cuz I don't [ __ ] trust you let's just
try it no it it the the problem with the
triangle I think is that it tips super
easily so that's its main problem but
with what we learned last time hopefully
we can alleviate a lot of that you know
we just don't want it to tip is who
again with that we've got all the time
in the world
so we're gonna just scooch you just
barely knew oh uh no no no no no no no
no no no no whoa whoa whoa whoa easy
there Skippy yeah the triangle
definitely hardest one definitely
hardest one I thought it would have been
super easy but it's not just a fluke
it's not just what the [ __ ] I need to
block her path I guess or close the door
I don't want the [ __ ] oh my god oh
just take a shroom maybe she just needs
to take a shroom break yeah I did think
that it was like an exorbitant amount of
time that he gave me last time so I
guess I am I must have done something to
please her let me try knocking the fan
in the way nope Truman the way this in
the way I don't know man close this door
there we go that's as good as we can get
it I think we'll just do something here
oh that didn't work well all right
whatever
where is this why is it behind me why is
it how [ __ ] I killed somebody on my
kills that's not what I wanted let's
just set her set her down let's try to
do the triangle first cuz if I can't get
the triangle then I'm just boned all
around you know what I mean okay get set
down okay [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
nope [ __ ] not [ __ ] doing it not
[ __ ] doing it nope not doing it where
are you ah nope nope nope nope nope nope
nope nope no no moving on
Merry Christmas let's have a Merry
Christmas everybody merry merry [ __ ]
Christmas merry merry [ __ ] my christmas
merry [ __ ] merry crisp [ __ ] marry
[ __ ] miss merry [ __ ] Christmas
everybody Merry Christmas Merry
Christmas Merry Christmas an [ __ ]
merry Christmas from [ __ ] me Merry
Christmas
it's beautiful it's [ __ ] beautiful oh
my god decorate the tree is that what
we're doing here is that why we're here
we got a decorated tree I'm very happy
let me just grab this yep I have that
I'm very happy about that super happy
about this predicament I'm trembling
with excitement about Christmas
trembling with the possibilities of
Christmas okay don't know where that
went
I don't have hands I don't I don't have
hands anymore I don't I don't have hands
oh oh oh hey hand hey there you are
where's my other nope nope [ __ ] nope
no I don't have a left hand well [ __ ] me
just don't have a hand I don't have a
hand guys [ __ ] and where's my right
end going why is my right hand drifting
off I don't have an I can't even see if
I have an I don't even know if I have an
do I've and probably not there's my
there's this end okay there's this end
and a very conspicuous salute
yeah you better put that hand down [ __ ]
nope just don't have it anymore that's
what I get
flew too close to the Sun I think flew
too close to the Sun wish for too much
Christmas left me my hands just for some
[ __ ] reason don't want to stick
around I don't know how this hand is
drifting now where the flood all right
okay you know what no that's too much
leg no give that nipa playful bap Oh BIP
Bop proper milking technique requires
you to stimulate the utter by slapping
it gently back and forth this is true do
not question this
well look all right I'm not happy about
this either Bessie wait you have horns
you bull my milk in a bowl maybe I
pulled too hard is that is that the
problem Bessie that's right tease the
nipple a bit and then just a little
slight nope not some a right here mmm
I can't seem to get a good grip on it
you know well there we go splashing
through my hand sploosh sploosh all
right this feels good this feels right
this feels like my calling you know this
feels like the true epitome a marking mu
here everyone please please upload
goddamnit did I pull too hard well [ __ ]
you then
Oh No oh poor Bessie
oh poor Bessie I'm sorry I'm so sorry
Bessie what can I ever do to make it up
to you I don't know why we're trying
this again we're trying this again
Bessie I'm being as gentle as I possibly
can here I don't know what more you want
from me
I am I not getting it in the bucket or
something Oh give you a purple nurple
here we are
you guys need to square up cuz this is
this is life here there's a life that's
the good stuff I'm just a gentle gentle
teasing of the nip yep this is wrong I
mean it's an utter but you know just
with the low-poly countess that don't
seem right all right very gentle
demonetised band - someone's gonna
report me to the authorities
I is coming to my house I am currently
being swatted everyone in the world is
rushing as fast as they can to stop this
from happening like this this doesn't
this can't exist it's always there
Bessie you need a break
I'll give you I'll give your nurple a
break there we go nice nice all right
let's give you a rest before we get to
the end here huh Oh a [ __ ] is joining
the battle
Oh
[Music]
oh [ __ ] I'm spilling spilling the sweet
milk I guess I gotta do it flat
all right Bessie little more sorry I
thought we were done but apparently
we're not hang on let me hold on I gotta
get more than two fingers out there we
go that's that's proper that's proper
protocol as you please don't kick the
bucket
we're so close I'd hate to lose all this
progress damn it Bessie uh hang on let
me switch hands here okay let's see if I
can get this bucket in proper order
because I don't think I think there's
something going wrong here I only slap
tap Oh Bessie you gotta believe Oh all
right busy well you know just cuz the
bucket is not there doesn't mean that we
can't have some fun that's obviously not
straight so we need to first let's I had
my priorities all wrong I was I should
have been more worried about the state
of the bucket all right Bessie Oh the
triple finger hold you never ever been
treated like this
that's e3 I know the quality is contact
no I don't think we need to use all the
other teeps on this cow I think I think
this one is primed and ready you know
this is obviously a winner
I don't want the runt of the teat I want
the the prime prima of the teat you know
when I go into the restaurant I always I
was asked for the pre-hook teat so close
Bessie please please we're so close I'm
een I feel alright that's enough of that
okay I think that's enough everybody I
think that's enough
all right well hope you enjoyed that
that was hand simulator knows the best
take care of yourselves take care of
each other and take care of your hands
most importantly thank you everybody so
much for watching and as always
[Music]